During world war II, the Nazis were terrified of a mysterious female spy.
They called the limping lady.
Hundreds of posters with her face were plastered in every major French city.
And yet she managed to slip by undetected. This was Virginia Hall,
an American spy living in Nazi occupied FRAs.
She walks with a limp on a prosthetic leg called Kapi. Even with her disability.
She still managed to orchestrate jail breaks for POWs, run resistance,
newspapers, and get vital information back to the allies.
Even Klaus Barbie,
the butcher of Leo considered her to be one of the most dangerous allied spies.
And he was on a personal mission to hunt her down. So who was Virginia Hall?
And how did she become one of the most successful Spiess in all of history?
Virginia Hall was born on April the sixth, 1906 in Baltimore, Mar her father,
Edward Lee hall was an entrepreneur who helped to run banks and movie theaters
in the city.
Her mother Barbara was hard to be his secretary and they fell in love.
Virginia had one brother named John and their family lived in mansion in
Baltimore. They would spend summer vacations traveling through Europe,
and she grew up with all of the finest things in life.
Virginia's mother was not born into wealth,
so she fully embraced new upper class lifestyle.
She wanted Virginia to marry a well to do a man in high society.
Barbara made sure that her daughter received the best education at an all girls
academy called the Rolands park country school. However,
Virginia was not the date young women that her mother had hoped for.
She always played the male roles in the school plays because she wanted to
perform the sword,
become the hero who saved the day when she was outside of her school uniform,
she dressed in trousers and check of chats.
After school,
she would go through the woods to hunt rabbits and even wore live snakes as
bracelets, her classmates, they respected her confidence and her self-assurance.
So they voted her in as editor of the school,
newspaper and class president Virginia was studying languages at a prep school.
And she told everyone that she dreamed of becoming a diplomat so that she could
travel around the world and have amazing adventures.
Her father fully embraced her ambition and helped pay for language tutoring.
However, her mother continued to push her to act like a dignified young woman in
Baltimore society. After graduating from high school,
Virginia studied at some of the most prestigious women's universities in the
country. She attended both Barnard college in New York city and Radcliffe,
which is a part of Harvard university.
Her mother had been scheming for years to set Virginia up with men who she
considered to be good enough to marry her daughter.
She arranged for Virginia to court, a young man when she was just 19 years old,
they became engaged rather quick because their families wanted to unite their
businesses. Unfortunately,
her mother didn't seem to realize that just because a man has a trust fund and
an Ivy league education that doesn't make him a good person.
Virginia's fiance was cheating on her constantly,
and they were not actually in love with one another.
She knew that if she chose this path, that her parents wanted her to take,
she would never be happy. In the end.
She chose to follow her dream of becoming that hero,
who would have great adventures.
Virginia listened to a, her intuition.
She broke off her engagement so that she could move to France.
She transferred to a university in Paris called a called Libra Des science
politic. During her time living in Europe as a student,
she was able to practice the language with other native speakers and became
fluent in French, as well as Spanish, Russian, German, and Italian. However,
when she spoke it,
it was always a dead give of a way that she was a foreigner because she could
never, she her American accent after spending the end of her college years,
enjoying the Paris nightlife in the roaring twenties, she moved to Vienna,
Austria. This is where she fell in love with a Polish army officer named mill.
They wanted to get married, but her trip to Europe,
it was fully funded by her father. Out of respect for her parents,
Virginia wrote to her father to ask his permission. Sadly,
he foray her for marrying a mill because he believed that her life in Europe was
just a phase. Her parents,
they still wanted her to move back to the United States to carry on the family
legacy in Baltimore.
She beta father's wishes and broke things off with a mill Virginia returns,
the United States in 1929,
just in time to witness the beginning of the great her family's finances were
hit so hard that they almost lost everything to make matters worse.
Her father died of a sudden heart attack from all of the stress of his life.
Just crumbling around him.
This left their family even more financially destitute them before.
Now that snobby and sense of entitlement that her mother held onto for so long,
it was gone.
The family was no longer a part of high society in Virginia was free to pursue
her dreams. Once again,
she decided that she would leave the United States and apply for a job at the
American embassy in Warsaw, Poland,
as the consulate services clerk making $2,000 a year,
which is roughly $30,000 after inflation.
It's probably not a coincidence that she chose to move to Poland.
It had not been very long since she broke off her engagement with a mill and she
probably hoped that she could find them again. Sadly though,
that never happened.
Most historians believed that he would've died during world war II.
Since he had a career in the Polish military and the Nazis kill so many people
when they occupied Polands, while working at the embassy in Warsaw,
Virginia was given administrative tasks like decoding messages and filing paid
paperwork. This was nothing like the adventurous life that she had imagined.
She took a diplomat sentence exam and scored a hundred percent with her language
schools, her Ivy league education and Astella resume.
She should have been able to easily move out of a clerical position.
Every time there was a job opening,
she tried to apply and then they would lose her application.
Virginia could tell that the odds were stacked against her.
She believed that maybe the problem was isolated to Poland.
So she decided to transfer to the American embassy in Ismea Turkey.
Once she was living in Turkey, she tried to make friends with her new coworkers,
despite having so many setbacks.
She hoped that maybe she could become one of the special few women who were
accepted as diplomats,
but the plans for her future career were completely ruined when she was out on a
hunting trip with some friends,
Virginia was trying to climb over a wire fence when her gun accidentally went
off and she shot herself points blank in the foot.
She fell and sank into the mud, dirt and bacteria poured into the hole.
That was her shut added foot.
Her friends wrapped her foot in a tonic can carried her to the car.
She was in the hospital for three weeks,
but bacteria had gotten indu her open wounds and it caused an infection that
began to spread throughout her entire leg.
Just a few days before Christmas,
the leg had to be amputated from the knee down at 27 years old,
she became permanently disabled for the rest of her life.
The doctors gave her a wood and peg leg and she named it Kaber after learning to
walk with her prosthetic,
Virginia was still determined to continue working towards her goal.
She applied to work at the consulates in Venice, Italy,
and past the oral language assessments with flying colors.
But once they saw her leg,
they rejected her immediately and forbid her from taking the diplomats exam,
Virginia. She was fuming. So she wrote a to the secretary of state cordal hu.
He wrote back that hall could become a fine career girl outta the consular
service. As in he thought she should continue to be a clerical assistant.
Along with the rest of the women who worked at the embasies,
the secretary of state officially banned her from ever applying for higher
positions. Again, she had absolutely no hope left of ever becoming a diplomat
For the next few years,
Virginia Hall kept her head down and continued to do clerical work,
that she was clearly unhappy. Even after her aspirations had been shot down.
She still dreamed of going on those adventures after world Wari began,
Virginia felt compelled to help in any way she could.
So she decided leave her job and moved back to France in 1939,
she is now 33 years old and completely started her life over again from scratch
as an ambulance driver. Just one year later in 1940 Nazi, Germany, occupied,
France and Virginia had to escape through the Peries mountains in Spain and
France on a trail known as Le shemen Del Levite or the freedom trail,
the journey of 72 kilometers off 44 miles with elevations as high as 6,000 feet.
This typically takes three to four days for even abled bodied people to
complete.
And it would've taken Virginia Hall even longer with a disability during the
course of the war. Over 2000 experience,
mountain guides who led groups through the freedom trail were captured and
executed by the Nazi seasoned thousands of civilians who were taken prisoner.
So somehow despite the pain she experienced with her prosthetic leg,
Virginia Hall climbed through the mountain trails undetected.
Once she arrived in England,
Virginia Hall went straight to the American embassy in London to volunteer her
services to the British special operations executive or the SOE.
Now that the nation was a war,
the English knew that they could use her special abilities.
They were impressed with her language skills and agreed to bring her on as one
of their own spies. The SOE trained her in weaponry security communications,
as well as resistance activity. They gave her the code name heckler.
Once she received her training,
Virginia had to hike back into France on foot through the Peries mountains.
Once again, during the journey,
she ran into some issues and contacted the SOE saying Kubert was giving her
trouble. They responded. If Kubert is giving you difficulty have him eliminated.
They had no idea that she was talking about her leg in 1941.
She was back in France with false identification and pretended to be a newspaper
reporter from the New York post.
She was actually publishing secret intelligence that she had gathered from a spy
network that she had created more than 2 million people in France were able to
get valuable information through these resistance newspapers.
Whenever the British SOE spies made the way into France,
they had to report to this mysterious agent heckler.
Every single day was a new adventure for her on several occasions.
She saved the lives valid P pilots who'd survived from that down aircraft.
Anytime she recovered a pilot or a prisoner,
she brought them to a safe house where they could receive medical attention.
As time went on,
Virginia began to plan more and more ideas about how she could help the allies
together with a French doctor named Jeane.
They blotted jail breaks to free prisoners of war from Nazi camps.
Dr. Rae worked at a mentalist asylum and they had to transport patients on a
regular basis.
So as long as the POWs could pretend to be mentally ill in the back of the
ambulance, they were able to bring the men across the checkpoints.
Then Virginia would help guide them on a multi J journey into the United Kingdom
across the freedom trail. Of course,
Virginia Hall was far from being the only allied spy who is working in France.
She was just one of the most successful during world war II.
Great Britain sent 400 SOE agents into France and a hundred of them were
captured and killed to the Nazis.
She was just a helpless woman who walked with a limp. However,
while her physical disability should have made her less suspicious,
it was also a very specific trait that made her stand out from the crowd.
It was rare to see a young woman walking with a li and a prosthetic leg.
The more Virginia wents above and beyond to save people.
The more of a reputation she earns news began spreading that a limping woman
named agent heckler was helping the allied troops in plain sight.
Kabar was the chief of the gustapo in Leon France.
And he heard the news of agents heckler and elaborate pow jail breaks.
No one knew who heckler truly was or what country she came from.
The only dead giveaway was her accents. However,
Klaus Barbie must have had a hard time believing an American could be so fluent
in French. So he was once quoted as saying,
I would give anything to get my hands on that limping Canadian Barbie ordered
his men to hang over 200 posters of Virginia Hall's face.
And it read simply the limping lady, the most dangerous allied spies.
We must find her and destroy her. If it had a bounty on her head,
offering a reward for anyone who could come forward with information about her.
Whereabouts,
eventually someone was tempted enough to turn her secret location over to the
gustapo. In November of 1942,
she sent a message back to London that the address of her safe house had been
compromised. They ordered her to run.
She told them before she could escape that she must save two captured SEO agents
named Alex and Fabian. However,
just as she was attempting to break them out of jail,
a huge influx of Nazi soldiers showed up.
They just arrived after defeating territories in north Africa.
These were thousands of fresh eyes who were seeing the wanted posters for the
very first time.
And they would be on the lookout for the young women with the distinctive limp.
Once she saw the soldiers,
it was clear to Virginia that if she did not leave immediately,
she would be captured.
She packed her bags and left town just in the Nick of time,
because the very next day Dr. Jean Rue was arrested and killed for running is
underground escape route in the asylum. The gustapo burst into heckler HQ,
but she was already gone.
Virginia Hall had just barely a 24 hour head start on making her way back across
the freedom trail. This was just enough time to save her life. However,
just as Virginia Hall could practically see her freedom.
On the other side of the horizon,
the Spanish police arrested her for illegally crossing.
She was brought to jail at the very least.
She wasn't in the hands of the Nazi seasons. She could finally get some rest.
We're not sure just how long Virginia Hall spent living in a Spanish jail cell,
but she had to contact the American embassy in order for them to finally release
that. Once she was free,
Virginia contacted the SOE and let them know that she was alive and well after
spending time in prison,
she was even more eager to get back to helping with the war effort.
She requested to be sends back into France because she felt that her duty,
it was not over.
They refused saying that the gustapo already knew who she was and while they
were right, illustrations of Virginia's likeness were hung on,
wanted posters all over. She occupied Europe.
It would simply be far too risky to send her back.
As far as the SOE was concerned,
agent heckler had done her duty and they didn't expect anything more from her.
Once she knew that the British would not take her back.
She took a break from being a spy until 1944.
This is when she learns about the planned invasion of Normandy.
She met up with the American office of strategic services or the OSS for short.
This was the precursor to the CIA. Since her face was recognizable,
they helped her to dress up as an elderly woman.
This was actually the perfect disguise because it looked totally natural for an
older woman to be limping.
They also taught her Morse code and she learned how to become a radio operator
to send messages back to the Americans as quickly as possible.
After returning to France as an old woman,
Virginia they'd goat milk and lived out a daily existence as a milk mate,
yet again, the Nazis thought that she was harmless.
So Virginia was able to hide in plain sight,
delivering milk and cheese to the camps.
As the Germans openly discussed top secret information right in front of her,
they had no idea that she could speak fluent German after identifying their most
vital locations.
Virginia contacted the allies over the radio to helped you orchestrate the
bombings of several bridges and major Nazi infrastructures throughout France,
before the allies even reached the shores of Normandy on Dday,
even in the midst of battle,
she was on the ground sabotaging as much Nazi as she possibly could.
The Americans celebrated their victory over the Nazi season.
No one ever knew that they needed to thank Virginia Hall for prepping the road
to their victory.
When the war was finally over in 1945,
Virginia Hall was recognized for serving our country.
She was one of the only women to receive the distinguished service cross of the
United States of America.
Even though this was such a prestigious honor and the world would've been
shocked to know just how much she contributed to the allied victory.
She requested for the award ceremony to be held in secret.
She did not want the newspapers to show pictures of her face because she wanted
to continue working as a spy. The office of strategic services was renamed.
The central intelligence agency or CIA and Virginia Hall would go on to become
one of their very first female secret agents.
After years of focusing on her career,
she finally got married when she was 44 years old to a fellow spy named Paul
GAO. The CIA gave Virginia and Paul new alias,
and they were sent to work in Venice,
Italy to monitor the progress of communism in the country. For several years,
she gathered data on financial and political information and transmitted it back
to the United States.
Then she joined a division of the CIA called national committee for free Europe.
And before retiring, when she turned at 60, even after she was retired,
she knew that the missions she participated in were still top secrets.
So she never revealed the details of her exploits.
And she never gave a single interview.
She lived to be 76 years old and died in 1982 years after a death,
a CIA agent named Craig R Graley read the documents of Virginia Hall's
incredible story.
And he felt inspired to retrace her steps on the freedom trail.
He wanted to experience what it must have been like for,
to go through the mountains, even as an able bodied man,
he stumbled multiple times and almost fell to his death.
Graley wrote I'm hiking above 6,000 feet and have stumbled twice on this
narrowed, Rocky trail, deep in the French Peres. There's nothing to grab onto.
If I fall an really thorny brush and an occasional scrub pine GLING to the steep
mountain slope today, she continues to inspire people with her story. As a spy,
Virginia Hall kept most of her life as secrets because she was fighting to keep
people safe from the Nazi regime.
She quietly behind the scenes without ever expecting fame or glory in the end.
She truly did accomplish her dream of going down in history as a true hero.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We got brand new videos just like this four times per week. Also,
if you want more from me, why not check on my other channel called today?
I found out I'm gonna link to that below and as always, thank you for watching.